you want to see if you're a brave person
what they call the four o'clock in the
morning courage wait when things go
completely to Pieces when things are the
worst when your very best deal falls
apart and your rent is late and you're
tired and you're sick and everybody is
mad at you and your car doesn't work
then it's the person that picks
themselves up and says nothing is going
to stop me you know you know the best
quality in the world that you can
develop and I give it to you because
I've made it my life's Habit to develop
this call I hope I've got it I don't
know for sure but the quality is to
develop the quality of being Unstoppable
say in yourself that no matter what life
throws at me it'll never stop me no
matter how rough it gets I will never
quit and nothing will ever stop me